a house as old as this one becomes in
time a living thing sound design is
actually one of the sort of the great
unsung heroes of cinema any movies fifty
percent audio fifty percent visuals we
try to play with all the surround
channels when we mix the movie we may
get a 360 experience
sound design and this is actually
amazing and it's something I know gamma
spend a long time on that he wanted the
floorboards to creak in just the right
way and he wanted the shadows to clutter
and mow in a truly scintillating in
terrifying way I think it's one of the
most sort of powerful senses and
experiencing it with those elements and
music and sound just really made it very
powerful I hope that audiences feel that
they're pulled into the imagination of
Guillermo del Toro and they are immersed
in the precision and detail that he's
brought to bear on this phone you are
surrounded by atmosphere you hear a
little creek on the right back side so
it's a very active mix and I think again
the system in imax will will translate
beautiful
I max is completely immersive as an
experience your experience can be really
enhanced by imax because there's this
kind of vertiginous effect of being
dropped into the world of the film it's
almost as if you're living within it you
have nowhere else to go this is your
home now